and I played five rounds of golf and her
lowest score was an 80 the firt the
scores of the first four rounds and the
lowest round are shown in the following
dot plot and we see it right over here
the lowest round she scores an 8000
scores a 90 once a 92 once and 94 once
and a 96 once it was discovered that Ana
broke some rules when she scored 80 so
that scores cheating didn't help her so
that score will be removed from the data
set so they removed that 80 right over
there were just left from the with the
scores from the other four rounds
how will the removal of the lowest round
affect the mean and the median
so let's actually think about the median
first so the median is the middle number
so over here when you had five data
points the middle data point is going to
be the one that has two to the left and
two to the right so the median up here
is going to be ninety two the median up
he there is ninety two and what's the
median once you remove this now you only
have four data points when you're trying
to find the median of an even number of
numbers you look at the middle two
numbers so that's a 92 and a 94 and then
you take the average of them you go
halfway between them to figure out the
median so the median here is going to be
let me do that a little bit clearer the
median over here is going to be halfway
between 92 and 94 which is 93 so the
median the median is 93 median is 93 so
removing the lowest data point in this
case increase the median so the median
let me write down here so the median
increased by a little bit the median
increases now what's going to happen to
the mean what's going to happen to the
mean well one way to think about it
without even doing any calculations is
if you remove a number that is lower
than the mean lower than the existing
mean and I haven't calculated what the
existing mean is but if you remove that
the mean is going to go up the mean is
going to go up so hopefully that gives
you some intuition if you removed a
number that's larger than the mean your
mean is your mean is going to go down
because you don't have that
large number anymore if you have remove
a number that's lower than the mean well
you take that out you don't have that
that small number
bringing the average down and so the
mean will go up but let's verify it
mathematically so let's calculate the
mean over here so we're going to add 80
plus 90 plus 90 to plus 90 4 plus 96
those are our data points and that gets
us 2 + 4 6 plus 6 is 12 and then we have
1 plus 8 is 9 and we essentially this is
so these are 9 and you have another 9
another night another night another 9
you essentially have is this five nines
right over here so this is going to be
450 450 - so that's the sum of the
scores of these five rounds and then you
divide it by the number of rounds you
have so it'd be 450 2 divided by 5 so
450 2 divided by 5 is going to give us
five goes into doesn't go into 4 it goes
into 45 9 times 9 times 5 is 45 you
subtract you get 0 bring down the 2 5
goes into 2 0 times 0 times 5 is 0 2
times 5 is 0 subtract you have 2 left
over so you can say that the mean here
the mean here is 90 and two-fifths maybe
not 9 into fifths 90 and two-fifths so
the mean is right around here so that's
the mean of these data points right over
there and if you remove it what is the
mean going to be so here we're just
going to take our 90 plus our 92 plus
our 94 plus our 96 add them together so
let's see 2 plus 4 plus 6 is 12 and then
you add these together going to get 37
372 divided by 4 because I have four
data points now not five four goes into
three let me do this in a place where
you can see it so 4 goes into 372 goes
into thirty seven nine times 9 times 4
is 36
subtract you know one bring down the two
goes exactly three times three times
four is 12
you have no remainder so the median and
the mean here are both so this is also
the mean the mean here is also 93 so you
see that the median the median went from
92 to 93 it increased the mean went from
90 and two-fifths to 93 so the mean
increased by more than the median they
both increased but the mean increased by
more and it makes sense because you this
number was way way below all of these
over here so you can imagine if you take
this out the median should increase by a
good amount but let's see which of these
choices are what we just described but
the mean and the median will decrease
nope both the mean and the median will
decrease nope both the mean and the
median will increase but the mean will
increase by more than the median that's
exactly that's exactly what happened the
mean went from 90 and 2/5 or 90.4 went
from ninety point four or 90 and
two-fifths to 93 and then the median
only increased by one so this is the
right answer